if you were to go back to yourself in
1998 having a time pass from that spirit
award nomination and also going to send
dance and being thrust into this world
and almost made to be like superhuman
yeah what would you tell yourself now
you know that's a difficult question
because I had such a great time and I
wouldn't want to deprive myself of that
naivety you know of the sort of novelty
of it all to try and go and it's
difficult I know because when you're an
adult and you see a kid who's doing
certain something and you want to sort
of give them advice so that they don't
make the mistakes that you make a lot of
it is learning from your mistakes and
experiencing it on your own so I yes I
think I would definitely tell myself
certain things but I think it's probably
best that I don't is that it could one
one thing that i may do different may
put me in a different place now so i
think it was all just worth it
experience there is this sort of thing
that that people come here and like the
minute you get off the bus you're going
to be famous and i never saw it as
wanting to be famous I saw it as a
career and a career spans a lifetime so
I have my entire life to succeed and
that's how I've always looked at it so
there was never this I need to be a star
tomorrow my name has to be big tomorrow
today you know what like I have to be a
movie star that was never because you
see someone like Kathy Bates who later
in her ears you know got an Oscar so you
can Betty White it's a great example of
how she's mad
now you know in terms of her career so
if you look at it as a career that you
will be doing for your entire life you
will always have these moments these
highlights where you'll succeed and and
do well but as long as you're consistent
with the work and you want to do good
work i think that that will definitely
get you there eventually maybe tomorrow
or maybe in 10 years from now
you